nach dem amoklauf eines 18 jährigen in
texas stehen die usa immer noch unter
schock der 18-jährige salvador ramos
hatte mit einem sturmgewehr 19
schulkinder und zwei lehrerinnen
erschossen bevor er selbst von
sicherheitskräften erschossen wurden
doch nun kommen auch immer mehr
schockierende hintergründe ans licht so
hat der 18 jährige schütze anscheinend
kurz vor der bluttat mit mehreren
internet bekanntschaften gechattet und
auch andeutungen darüber gemacht was er
grausam es vorhat und unter diesen chat
kollegen ist auch eine 15 jährige
deutsche aus frankfurt
ich gehe jetzt eine grundschule zu
erschießen das schreibt der amokläufer
salvador ramos einem mädchen in einem
chat die empfängerin der nachricht eine
15 jährige schülerin in frankfurt im
messenger von facebook schreibt er ihr
ich verrate dir was wenige minuten vor
seiner bluttat
ich warte auf diese [ __ ] ich werde
ihr etwas antun
sie ist am telefon wegen eines
handyvertrags sie ist nervig dass ich
habe gerade meine oma in den kopf
geschossen jetzt gehe ich grundschüler
erschießen die 15-jährige antwortet
darauf nur ich habe eben die nachricht
hin gesehen laut cnn lernten sich der
amokläufer und die schülerin am 9 mai im
internet über ein soziales netzwerk
kennen hatten mehrere wochen kontakt
telefonierten täglich per facetime
miteinander laut der schülerin wollte
der attentäter sie sogar in deutschland
besuchen doch nicht nur ihr schrieb der
amokläufer anscheinend zufällig schreibt
er einer anderen frau auf instagram zwei
wochen vor der tat verlinkt er sie auf
einem post auf dem zwei
schnellfeuergewehre zu sehen sollte was
haben deine waffen mit mir zu tun fragt
sie ihn inzwischen hat sie den
tatverlauf veröffentlicht wie postest du
meine waffen bilder fragt der attentäter
was haben deine waffen mit mir zu tun
ich wollte dich einfach verlinken
antwortet ramos und dann kurz vor seinem
amoklauf schreibt er ich bin kurz davor
was kurz davor was guten morgen ich sage
es dir vor 11 uhr guten morgen guten
morgen
ich schreibe dir in einer stunde aber du
musst antworten als die junge frau etwas
später auf diese forderung antwortet
reagiert ramos nicht mehr hat offenbar
schon mit den vorbereitungen für sein
massaker begonnen nach wie vor ist ihr
schleierhaft warum der täter
ausgerechnet sie als vertrauensperson
ausgesucht hat die laut us-berichten
minderjährige frau lebt nach eigenen
angaben nicht in texas und muss nun
damit fertig werden einen massenmörder
unwissentlich bei seiner tat begleitet
zu haben
ja wirklich unfassbar und die
anteilnahme bei der trauerfeier für die
schulkinder und die lehrer ist gewaltig
und auch eine schauspielerin
schauspielerin megan merkel trauert um
die vielen opfer des amoklaufs sehen sie
hier wie sie eben weiße rosen an der
gedenkstätte vor ort in juval die die
darlegt
wir schauen jetzt auch einmal auf die
tatwaffen denn es ist ja wirklich
unglaublich dass ein 18-jähriger solche
dinger einfach kaufen kann rund 2500
euro hat der schütze für dieses
hochmoderne visier gezahlt an einen
online shop wo er die tatwaffe wenige
tage vor seinem amoklauf an seinem
achtzehnten geburtstag gekauft haben
soll ja und besonders makaber der online
händler wirbt auf seiner seite für die
tödliche ware mit fotos von kleinkindern
und waffen
tja die usa und ihre waffengesetze nicht
erst seit dem amoklauf von vaude werden
diese laschen waffengesetze diskutiert
doch sämtliche initiativen gegen
schärfere gesetze in den usa sind
bislang folgenlos geblieben ja die
waffenlobby n a sie gehört zu den
mächtigsten organisationen in den usa
wenige tage nach dem horror amoklauf
die usa trauern
[Musik]
trauern um die 19 toten kinder und zwei
getöteten lehrerinnen des amoklaufs von
verdi
[Musik]
die grausame bluttat auch ermöglicht
durch die laschen waffengesetze in den
staaten
amerika überschlägt sich in der
diskussion um die gefährlichen gewähre
[Musik]
14 kinder
in einer grundschule in texas
was machen wir
er wird jedes mal wenn so eine tragödie
passiert brechen unsere herzen doch
unsere gebrochenen herzen sind nichts im
vergleich zu den gebrochenen herzen der
betroffenen familie
im nass genug ist genug
mein herz wurde heute gebrochen wir sind
eine kleine gemeinschaft
wir brauchen eure gebete das
durchzustehen ist
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dann werden wir etwas tun
ich bin es so leid den zerstörten
familien mein leid auszusprechen
[Musik]
das ich bin ist so leid ich bin diese
schweigeminuten so lange muss wahl und
es ist genug
ich hatte gehofft dass ich das nicht tun
musst du schon wieder ein massaker
in einer grundschule
wunderschöner unschuldige zweit dritt
und viertklässler
ich denke an die eltern die ihren
kindern nie wieder in ihren betten
springen werden die ihre kinder nie
wieder kuscheln können
gott segne den verlust dieser
unschuldigen seelen an diesem traurigen
tag
[Musik]
denn trotz dieser vielen emotionalen
appelle auch des us-präsidenten trotz
der vielen toten die waffenlobby sie
zeigt sich weiterhin unbeeindruckt
während eltern im uvg die begräbnisse
ihre schulkinder vorbereiten kommt die
energie tatsächlich zu ihrem
jahrestreffen zusammen und das
ausgerechnet im texanischen houston ja
tausende anhänger des unbegrenzten
waffen zugangs werden im georgia brown
convention center zum beginn des
spektakels erwartet aber auch zahlreiche
gegner die sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind
entsprechend hoch drei tage nach diesem
schulmassaker ist das timing denn die
show für viele fast unerträglich es gab
rufe nach einer absage doch die 150
jahre alte waffen vereinigung dieb
unbeirrt hauptredner am ersten tag ist
ex präsident donald trump
das tolle daran ist dass ich mit meinem
vater jedes jahr hierher kommen die seit
1994 ach nein seit 1997
ich komme hierhin um die werte unserer
verfassungsrechte
es ist etwas das wir seit jahren tun
normalerweise komme ich hier mit zehn
männern vorbei jedes jahr es ist so ein
männer ding
[Musik]
was gefällt ihnen die am besten die
waffen
ich bin hier um gegen die veranstaltung
protestieren wir brauchen waffengesetze
und hintergrund schätzt es gibt so viel
zu tun texas liebt waffen aber wie viele
kinder müssen noch sterben wir müssen
kämpfen unsere babys sterben
ich habe 30 bis 40 waffen zu hause
niemand will dass unsere kinder
erschossen werden aber das event zu
canceln würde nichts daran ändern
die schlechten menschen werden aber
immer an die waffen herankommen
ich finde wir sollten unsere kinder am
allermeisten schützen durch bewaffnete
polizisten oder security wir beschützen
unsere banken durch polizisten und
andere wenn wir unser geld beschützen
können warum können wir nicht unsere
kinder beschützt
mehr waffen werden gefordert um wiederum
weitere schießereien zu verhindern das
kann man hier in europa irgendwie nicht
so wirklich verstehen diese
argumentation vor allem nicht wenn man
sich statistiken wie dieser anschaut
schon schießereien immer wieder in den
usa es ist wirklich unfassbar
2022 jetzt also 21 tote an der rub
elementary school
2018 17 tote an der stoneman high und so
weiter also
449 schießereien insgesamt auf dem
schulgelände
129 tote und 2 170 verletzte und das nur
innerhalb von 2013 bis
2019 ja wirklich unfassbare zahlen und
wir wollen jetzt sprechen mit reife
freund der politischen organisation
republic brot denn die rolle der
republikaner ist bei dieser diskussion
um die verschärfung der waffengesetze
eben eine ganz wichtige er freunde wie
schätzen sie die waffengesetze in den
usa ein also die waffengesetze sind
unzulänglich sie sind günstiger aus
einer zeit als ist nicht diese sozialen
medien gar als es nicht möglicherweise
diese sozial repressionen gab und ich
glaube die waffengesetze bedürfen einer
anpassung ist auch die diskussion ist
unglaublich aufgeheizt es geht nicht
darum irgendwem waffen wegzunehmen auch
in deutschland kann man waffen kaufen am
jederzeit ist muss aber eine
identifikation stattfinden ein
polizeiliches führungszeugnis eingesehen
werden junge leute nicht damit 18 jahren
an dem achtzehnten geburtstag wie hier
geschehen
schnellfeuerwaffen im supermarkt kaufen
können man muss sich das alles
vorstellen dass der größte waffenhändler
der usa wal-mart ist die supermarktkette
also man geht dann rein und kaufte sich
ein je nach bundesstaat allerdings ein
schnellfeuergewehr und das sind dinge
die müssen einfach aufhören da bin ich
auch mit einem gewissen minderheit
meiner partei im einklang die sagt
waffen wegnehmen auf keinen fall eine
überprüfung der identifikation der
käufer ist absolut
dringlich erklären sie uns das mal sie
sagen selber sie sind da in der
minderheit war ihrer partei warum sind
die republikaner so strikt dagegen
irgendetwas an diesen waffengesetzen zu
ändern also auch für ihre zuhörer es ist
wichtig zu erfahren dass eben die linie
die da läuft nichts zwischen den
parteien verläuft die demokraten werden
also gm für strengere waffengesetze
republikaner und hat sich dagegen das
beste beispiel werden wir jetzt erleben
dieses jahr sind die mit haben die
großen zwischenwahlen wo der gesamte
kongress mit 35 17 neu gewählt wird in
ein drittel des senats und da werden wir
dann sehen wie groß dieses waffen thema
am hoch kommt ob das denn wirklich so
ist und wenn es denn so leicht wäre dann
würden auch die demokraten ja ganz stark
punkten können aber sie werden sehen es
ist gar nicht der fall es wird durchaus
auch demokratische bundesstaaten geben
die eben nicht für eine änderung der
waffengesetze eintreten wird und es wird
auch amerikanische bundesstaaten geben
die er für eine änderung eintreten es
ist ein bisschen das bild als eine
allgemeinheit hat warum ist das so nun
es gibt eben die einstellung im
fernwaffen für freien bürger und man
könnte sich ja selbst verteidigen das
kam in ihrem beitrag gut zum ausdruck
man könne sich selbst verteidigen im
sinne man könne auch den angreifer
abwehren
anstatt den guten in anführungsstriche
die waffen zu nehmen und den bösen die
immer an die waffen herankommen die
waffen zu lassen da ist dieser
selbstverteidigungs charakter in den usa
sehr aus ich habe mir noch einmal auf
die entwicklung was würden sie denn
sagen gibt es da eine reale chance jetzt
gerade mit diesem amoklauf als
hintergrund dass sich die waffengesetze
jetzt ändern werden oder was ist in
ihrer meinung glauben sie dass das eben
gar nicht passieren wird ist eine sehr
gute frage ich glaube nicht was wir
bekommen werden ist eine änderung von
oben nach dem verständnis wir müssen es
ein neues gesetz von oben einführen das
wird nicht passieren
so tragisch es ist es muss leider von
den bürgern kommt dass es in den wahlen
wie jetzt in den zwischenwahlen ein
großes thema wird dass man damit punkten
kann in waren solange man das nicht kann
wird es auch nichts passieren
bedauerlicherweise wir werden
potenzieller weise noch weitere
schießereien erleben das ist traurig
aber das ist die bittere politische
wahrheit im erstens ein umdenken bei der
bevölkerung gibt und das waren damit
auch wahlen gewinnen und waren verlieren
kann erst dann wenn wir eine änderung
bekommen sämtliche
ansprache auch das präsidenten die ich
durchaus unterstützt sämtliche andere
ansprachen werden fruchtlos bleiben
solange es da kein sinneswandel
innerhalb der bevölkerung
ja das ist wirklich die bittere wahrheit
vielen dank ralf freund für diese
einschätzung vizepräsident der
republicans overseas germany dankeschön